hey guys my name is just it is Thursday
and I've got a bunch of news for you so
here's what's going on first up old
school GTA fans rejoice as GTA online is
reviving the classic top-down camera
modes rockstar is bringing back the eye
in the sky camera angle with tiny racers
and you take on the stunt races that
forces the new camera angle as you
probably already know pre gta3 gta1 this
top-down perspective no more details
thus far on what else will be included
in tiny races but we do know that it's
arriving for ps4 Xbox one and PC on
April 25 we'll update you if we learn
anything new so go on and subscribe if
you want to stay up to date next up we
finally have a reason to shoot on this
sweet poster wall as Blizzard have
announced that overwatch is
controversial tiebreaker rule is
changing again prior to last week's 1.10
update draws in competitive matches were
resolved by both teams racing to capture
a tiebreaker point the update changed
this to a progress based system wherein
quote if neither team successfully
captures the objective a winner can be
determined based on which team captured
the largest portion this created a
problem however printable designer Scott
Mercer explained if team a is on Hanah
Muro defense and prevents team b from
ever gaining any capture progress and
when team a is on offense they only need
to reach one percent capture progress to
win the game
this means Team B needs to always have
someone contesting on the capture point
or they risk losing well is it are
tweaking the system so that teams will
need to reach at least 33% capture
progress to win a tie-break la Blizzard
admits the tweak will result in more
ties they feel quote the additional
clarity of the victory moment and
ability for the defense to react to the
offense are worth it the changes will be
rolled out in a future patch finally
we've got some brand new images and
details from that upcoming vampire game
code vein from bandai namco the
third-person action RPG in which you
feast on the blood of enemies in a
massive interconnected world is
scheduled to launch on all major home
consoles
20:18 so that probably means Xbox one
and ps4 not so much piecing according to
the official synopsis you'll play as a
revenant in the not-too-distant future
after a mysterious disaster destroy the
world you'll find yourself as part of a
hidden society of revenants called Vayne
who are fighting to survive you'll be
able to drain the blood of your enemies
in order to enhance your own abilities
known as gifts bandai namco explained
players can change their form to
increase their strength weaken enemies
and utilize new weapon abilities with
overpowered attacks utilizing the vast
array of weaponry along with each
character's gift players can adapt and
strategize to a variety of battle
conditions let's suit their play styles
that's everything we've got for you
today leave me your thoughts and
feelings in that comment section yes I
got a haircut and come back for a top
five stories of the whole week tomorrow
[Music]